digamos que tenemos una compañía aquí y
veamos cómo se está comportando al
mercado de valores y durante el
transcurso del día digamos que sus
acciones van teniendo este
comportamiento así que conforme pasa el
día su precio va cambiando pero digamos
que aquí dentro del día digamos que esto
ocurre a las 10 de la mañana hay un
anuncio y este anuncio dice que la
empresa ve trata de adquirir o de
fusionarse adquirir
la empresa a no sé suponiendo que
ahorita las acciones de a
se encuentran a cinco dólares cada
acción y en eso sale este anuncio de que
be trata de adquirir a
10 dólares la acción
y lo piensan pagar con efectivo ya
veremos en otros vídeos que es posible
que una compañía adquiera otra pagando
con sus propias acciones pero en este
caso piensa en pagar estas acciones con
efectivo así que una vez que sale este
anuncio de que ve trata de adquirir a
todas las personas que tienen una acción
de a obtendrán diez dólares por ella y
todas esas acciones irán a la compañía
ver y así la compañía a pertenecer a la
compañía ver y que creen ustedes que
pase con las acciones de la compañía a
justo cuando todos se enteran de que ve
trata de adquirir la compañía y bueno si
tenemos la certeza de que esto va a
ocurrir pues ya que todas las personas
que tienen una acción de a van a recibir
diez dólares por cada una pues se pueden
imaginar que esto de pronto va a llegar
a los diez dólares por acción o algo muy
cercano a
10 dólares la action y tampoco va a
haber mucha variación en este precio ya
que todos saben con certeza cuánto van a
recibir por cada acción eso es lo que
ocurre cuando tenemos la certeza de que
va a ocurrir esta adquisición o fusión
la realidad es que no sabemos con
certeza si esto se va a dar cuando hay
este tipo de anuncios ya que no sabemos
si efectivamente va a adquirir o podría
esperar aprobación de alguna entidad
gubernamental para asegurarse de que
aquí no se dé un monopolio quizás
todavía tienen que encontrar el
financiamiento para esto a lo mejor
están esperando la aprobación de un
préstamo bancario para poder hacer esta
adquisición o quizá otra cosa ocurre
quizá hay otra tercera empresa que está
interesada también en adquirir y están
dispuestos a pagar más así que no
tenemos la certeza de que es lo que va a
pasar aquí lo que normalmente ocurre es
que en lugar de que las acciones se
disparen en su precio directamente a
este valor
a cierto punto intermedio así que en
lugar de subir directamente de 5 a 10
dólares pues a lo mejor sube de 5 a 8
dólares a lo mejor están por acá y bueno
porque es que se compran o venden a 8
dólares bueno lo que sucede aquí es que
si hubiera una certeza del 100% de que
esto va a ocurrir todo se vendería a
diez dólares ya que eso es lo que
valdría a las acciones de a con
seguridad pero si se compra a ocho
dólares lo que en esencia está
ocurriendo en el mercado es que nos van
a dar tres quintas partes de este precio
de cinco a ocho hay tres dólares así que
nos darían tres quintas partes del total
del salto que podría darse si es que
tuviéramos una certeza del 100 por
ciento otra forma de verlo es que esto
indica que el mercado tiene una
probabilidad o considera que hay un 60
por ciento de probabilidad de que esto
se dé cualquiera que piense que hay una
probabilidad mayor a 60 por ciento al
mejor
hacen sus cálculos de probabilidad y
esto es lo que consideran que va a pasar
comprada en esas acciones ya que están
seguros de que aunque ellos los
comprenda 8 eventualmente las podrán
vender a 10 y cualquiera que piense que
esto no va a ocurrir de que algo va a
pasar pero ven no va a poder adquirida
por cualquiera que sea la razón pues
querrán vender o hice cortos cuando las
acciones lleguen a este punto ya que si
la adquisición no falla el valor de las
acciones va a regresar a donde estaba
antes al rango de los 5 dólares como
estaba antes del anuncio así que las
personas y en especial los fondos de
cobertura que actúan de esta manera que
piensan que esta fusión es probable que
ocurra o puede que no ocurra con base en
sus investigaciones o modelos
cuantitativos que tengan o quizá tienen
información que otras personas no poseen
que a lo mejor es legal o no
pues ellos establecerán estos valores si
ellos creen que esta adquisición va a
ocurrir entonces comprarán porque están
seguros que las acciones subirán y las
personas que no creen que esto ocurra se
van a ir cortas o van a vender en este
punto antes de que vuelva a bajar el
valor de la acción y esa estrategia de
adivinar las probabilidades de una
adquisición o una fusión se le llama
arbitraje
arbitraje de fusión
y se le llama arbitraje porque si hay
personas que creen que saben qué va a
pasar con esta adquisición pues podrán
comprar algo a 8 y ese algo están
seguros que vale 10 y venderlo a 10 en
una fecha futura cuando ve adquiera la
compañía o si ellos creen que esta
adquisición o esta función no va a
ocurrir van a quedarse cortos o van a
vender en 8 antes de que el precio
regrese a los 5 dólares y de esta manera
están haciendo un arbitraje con una
diferencia de precios del lado negativo
pues algo que venden a 8 antes de que
regrese a 5 y del lado positivo es algo
que compran a 8 y que valdrá 10